independent events are events that have
nothing to do with each other and
needless to say it's a lot easier to
work with them when because you don't
have to figure out some weird
interaction between two events that do
have something to do with each other
typical case where in independent events
come up is for example you toss a coin
five times and then you're about to toss
a coin the sixth time is there any
reason to think that what the coins did
the first five times is going to have
any influence on the flip of the sixth
court of the coin for the sixth time
well it's reasonable to assume not which
is to say that the outcome of the sixth
toss is arguably independent of the
outcome of all the previous tours of
tosses okay let's look at a formal
definition now in this short video of
just what is the technical definition of
independent events so what we said is
that they're independent if they have
nothing to do with each other what that
means is that if I tell you that B
happened it doesn't have any effect on
the probability of a that is the
probability of a given that B happened
doesn't change the probability of a at
all that's it now this is one definition
maybe this is the more intuitive
definition but a another definition
that's equivalent and is standard is
that two events are equivalent if the
product of their probabilities is equal
to the probability that they both happen
that is the probability of their
intersection now definition one and
definition two a trivial equivalent of
just using the definition of conditional
probability and if you don't see that
this would be a moment to stop get a
pencil and paper and write down the
three line proof of the equivalence of
these two equality's in fact the three
line proof has this is the first line
and that is the second line so you could
argue it's really just the middle line
that you're adding okay the definition
too has the slight advantage that it
always works whereas definition one
implicitly requires that the divisor
remember probability of a given B is
defined as the probability of the
intersection divided by the probability
but is only defined if the probability
of B is positive whereas the second
definition will always work so we don't
have to
put a proviso in about the probability
of B being on zero so that's the
definition of Independence looking at
this definition what you can see
immediately is that it's completely
symmetric in a and B since
multiplication is commutative and
intersection is commutative which is a
in which B doesn't matter and what that
implies then is that a is independent of
B if and only if B is independent of a
now another fact that holds is that if
the probability of B happens to be zero
then vacuously B is independent of
everything even itself which isn't
important but is a small technicality
that's worth remembering by that
definition now again the intuitive idea
that a and B have nothing to do with
each other is that a is independent of B
means that a is independent of whether
or not B occurs that is to say if a is
independent of being ordered the
independent of the complement of B and
that's a lemma that's also easily proved
a is independent of B if and only if a
is independent of the complement of B
it's a simple proof using the difference
rule and again I encourage you to stop
and with a piece a piece of paper and
pencil and convince yourself that that
follows with a one-line proof